[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons de
revoir l'examen mardi de la proposition
de loi consacré aux violences conjugales
vous avez entendu parler de ce texte car
au détour d'un amendement les sénateurs
ont débattu de l'accès aux sites
pornographiques
en effet le sénat a adopté à l'unanimité
un amendement qui impose aux sites
pornographiques de mettre en place un
contrôle de l'âge de leurs clients il
faut le savoir
emmanuel macron avait proposé d'encadrer
davantage ces sites pornographiques se
détend en novembre dernier il l'avait
dit devant l'unesco et donc les
sénateurs l'ont pris au mot et avec
l'accord du gouvernement ont adopté cet
amendement qui obligera les sites
pornographiques à mettre en place un
contrôle de l'âge de leurs clients
direction l'hémicycle pour suivre cette
séance préparer aujourd'hui pour public
sénat par louis beaulieu sa baie et
m'attire noutary monsieur le président
de la commission des lois madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la ministre cheikh
marlène schiappa vous savez mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs notre volonté de lutter
efficacement contre les violences
conjugales
dès le 9 mai 2019 j'ai pu adresser aux
procureurs généraux par circulaire une
instruction leur demandant de déployer
l'ensemble de notre arsenal répressif
afin de faire preuve de la plus grande
fermeté à l'égard des auteurs mais aussi
de mieux protéger les victimes
par exemple en utilisant largement les
téléphones graves dangers de 300
appareils distribués en février 2019
nous sommes ainsi passés à plus de mille
aujourd'hui cette volonté porté par
l'ensemble du gouvernement s'est
exprimée tout au long de la crise
sanitaire que nous venons de traverser
au delà des dispositifs de signalements
spécifiquement organisé par mes
collègues ou de la création d'une plate
forme d'hébergement et de suivi des
conjoints violents
j'ai pu prendre diverses mesures
j'ai ainsi tenu à ce que les violences
conjugales demeure un contentieux
prioritaires effectivement traitées par
les juridictions pendant la période de
confinement l'ordonance de protection a
donc figurer parmi les procédures
d'urgence qui était inscrite dans les
plans de continuation d'activité des
tribunaux avec selon un schéma
procédures fixées par circulaire un
traitement des nouvelles demandes dans
un délai de 6 jours conformément à la
loi du 28 décembre 2019 j'ai par
ailleurs veiller à faciliter les
démarches des victimes de violences
conjugales en prolongeant toutes les
ordonnances de protection dont le terme
était prévu entre le 12 mars et la fin
de l'état de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
augmenté d'un mois afin de tenir compte
du ralentissement de l'activité des
juridictions ainsi la loi du 11 mai 2020
ayant prorogé l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 10 juillet 2020 une ordonnance
de protection qui par exemple devait
s'achever le 1er avril 2020 continuera à
s'appliquer jusqu'au 10 octobre 2020 je
connais aussi mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs l'engagement
qui est le vôtre dans cette lutte contre
les violences commises au sein du couple
ces enjeux concernent la france toute
entière et notre société tout entière
cette volonté d'agir contre les
violences au sein de la famille s'est
traduite donc particulièrement dans la
loi du 28 décembre 2019 à laquelle je
faisais référence il ya quelques minutes
que vous avez adopté ce texte marque un
pas important dans ce combat car il
renforce les moyens de lutte contre ces
violences
en améliorant le traitement des requêtes
en ordonnance de protection en
favorisant l'aménagement de l'autorité
parentale en présence d'un crime
conjugal
notamment en instituant la suspension
automatique de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale d'un parent poursuivies ou
condamnées pour crimes commis sur la
personne de l'autre parent en permettant
également le déploiement du bracelet
anti rapprochement et en étendant le
champ d'application du téléphone grave
danger
j'ai tenu à présenter l'ensemble de ces
dispositions pour la plupart
d'application immédiate
dans une circulaire le 28 janvier 2020
hauts magistrats cette circulaire
comporte des instructions de politique
pénale
issu du des travaux du grenelle contre
les violences conjugales impulser et
piloté par ma collègue marlène schiappa
elles sont relatives ces mesures à
l'accompagnement des victimes au suivi
des auteurs et à l'organisation des
juridictions en faveur d'une filière
d'urgence dédié au traitement des
violences conjugales
la loi de décembre 2019 mais
spécifiquement l'accent sur les
ordonnances de protection et sur les
nouvelles mesures qui peuvent être
prononcées dans ce cadre on peut citer
l'interdiction de se rendre dans
certains lieux où se trouve de façon
habituelle la victime
la prise en charge sanitaire sociale ou
psychologique de l'auteur et la
possibilité pour celui-ci de suivre le
stage de responsables de
responsabilisation pour la prévention et
la lutte contre les violences au sein du
couple
ces nouvelles mesures ont été
favorablement accueillies dans les
juridictions qui se mobilisent pour
construire sur ce sujet des projets de
juridiction
les services du ministère de la justice
se sont également mobilisées pour
formaliser la nouvelle procédure de
délivrance des ordonnances de protection
afin de permettre aux juridictions de
statuer dans le délai de 6 jours
souhaité par le législateur le décret
portant application des articles 2 et 4
de la loi du 28 décembre 2019
ainsi été publiés le 28 mai dernier ce
décret supprime la convocation des
partis par lettre recommandée avec
accusé de réception qui manifestement
étaient devenus incompatibles avec le
délai de 6 jours
il unifie également les modalités de
saisine du juge au profit de la requête
signifier le décret précise les
conditions procédurales nécessaires au
respect du délai de 6 jours tout en
garantissant une procédure
contradictoire fondements de notre
procédure civile
je sais que d'aucuns trouvent ces
procédures trop strictes mais c'est un
décret qui tend à garantir la mise en
oeuvre des engagements du gouvernement
et la volonté du législateur
des échanges sont actuellement en cours
afin de faciliter l'accès aux huissiers
pour assurer leur signification dans les
délais requis les services travaille en
outre un possible doublement du délai de
signification dès demain une rencontre
avec des professionnels va nous
permettre d'avancer positivement sur ce
sujet le décret prépa créé par ailleurs
une passerelle entre la procédure
d'urgence de l' ordonnance de protection
et la procédure au fond relatives à
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et à
la contribution à l'entretien et
l'éducation de l'enfant grâce à cette
passerelle
le demandeur n'aura pas à former une
nouvelle demandons justice en cas de
rejet de sa demande d'ordonnancé de
protection il pourra obtenir rapidement
une décision au fond toujours trop peu
des livres et même si leur nombre est en
augmentation constante
j'ai souhaité constituer un comité de
suivi de l'ordonance de protection dont
j'ai confié la présidence à ernestine
ronai il pourra ce comité nous aiguiller
sur les améliorations toujours possible
de nos pratiques
mais notre engagement collectif va
encore plus loin
de nombreuses propositions issues du
grenelle contre les violences conjugales
organisée par le gouvernement ont été
formulées elles sont toutes destinées à
mieux prévenir et à mieux réprimer ces
violences et certaines exigent des
modifications de nature législative qui
trouvent leur expression dans la
proposition de loi visant à protéger les
victimes de violences conjugales dont
nous allons discuter aujourd'hui nourrit
des réflexions et des concertations
menées au sein des groupes de travail
mis en place par marlène dans le cadre
du grenelle ses propositions un texte
par madame la ministre schiappa ces
propositions intègre des notions
indispensables à la bonne compréhension
et au traitement adapté de ces violences
indigne de notre
ville isation ainsi le phénomène
d'emprise ce mécanisme qui place la
victime sous la domination et la
dépendance de son conjoint est
particulièrement prise en compte
il permet de comprendre le silence des
victimes et leur comportement craintif
qui fait croire à tort à une acceptation
de leur sort c'est pourtant cette
emprise qui les cloue auprès de leurs
bourreaux et peut entraîner et peut les
entraîner vers la mort la proposition de
loi que vous examiner aujourd'hui
modifie le code civil le code pénal et
le code de procédure pénale en
complétant la loi du 28 décembre 2019
sur des points importants en vue de
renforcer davantage encore la protection
effective des victimes de violence
familiale
qu'il s'agisse des parents ou des
enfants au plan pénal tout d'abord la
proposition de loi se concentre sur
trois axes majeurs premières acc
faciliter le signalement des violences
conjugales
à cette fin dans les cas de violence
d'une particulière gravité et qui
démontre la situation de l'emprise de la
victime
la proposition de loi donne la
possibilité aux médecins ou aux autres
professionnels de santé de porter ces
faits à la connaissance du procureur de
la république même s'ils n'ont pas
réussi à obtenir l'accord de la victime
j'aimerais jouer que ces dispositions
importantes et reçu l'accord de votre
rapporteur et de votre commission des
lois qui les ont non seulement approuvé
mais également améliorer les
modifications apportées au texte
l'initiative de votre rapporteur dont je
souligne ici la qualité du travail met
en effet très utilement en évidence que
le médecin appréciera en conscience
s'ils doivent ou non procéder à un
signalement
ces modifications clarifie également la
notion dans prises pour que le médecin
puisse plus aisément apprécier si un
signalement est ou non justifiés
deuxième axe au plan pénal il s'agit
d'améliorer les procédures pénales
concernant ces infractions
dans ce cadre il est prévu une
interdiction absolue du recours à la
médiation pénale en cas de violence
conjugale
ce qui répond à une demande ancienne et
répétées des associations et se justifie
par la situation dans prises dans
laquelle se trouve le plus souvent les
victimes
l'efficacité de la procédure est par
ailleurs accrue en permettant au juge
d'instruction ou juge des libertés et de
la détention d'ordonner en cas de
violence conjugale dans le cadre d'un
contrôle judiciaire et donc avant toute
condamnation
la suspension du droit de visite et
d'hébergement à l'égard des enfants y
compris en l'absence de violences
directes à leur encontre
dans le même esprit et renforcer la
possibilité pour les enquêteurs de
saisir des armes notamment au cours
d'une procédure pour violences au sein
du couple afin d'éviter qu'elle ne soit
utilisée par la personne mise en cause
le troisième axe au plan pénal toujours
vise à améliorer les incriminations et à
renforcer la répression
cela se traduit notamment par les points
suivants sera réprimée de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement et 150 mille euros
damende le harcèlement au sein du couple
qui aura conduit la victime à se
suicider ou a tenté de le faire les
comportements d'espionnage au sein du
couple seront plus largement incriminé
la lutte contre l'exposition mineurs à
la pornographie notamment sur des sites
internet sera amélioré par la précision
apportée à l'article 227-24 du code
pénal selon laquelle le délit sera
constituée y compris si l'accès d'un
mineur à des messages pornographiques
résulte d'une simple déclaration de
celui-ci indiquant qu'il est âgé d'au
moins 18 ans enfin le fait de donner
mandat à une personne de commettre des
crimes tels que le viol ou le délit
d'agression sexuelle sur un mineur sera
puni à titre autonome y compris si le
crime ou le délit n'a été ni commis ni
tenté
cela permettra notamment de poursuivre
et de condamner des personnes qu'ils
visionnent sur internet des sévices
sexuels qu'ils ont commandés commis
qu'ils ont commandité commis sur des
mineures à l'étranger voilà pour le plan
pénal
au plan civil la proposition de loi
prend en compte les conséquences
dévastatrices des violences commises au
sein du couple à l'égard de la victime
mais aussi de la famille
deux propositions sont faites en ce sens
concernant l'obligation alimentaire tout
d'abord en cas de violence conjugale
grave
la loi exclut toute possibilité de voir
les enfants victimes indirectes
contraint à soutenir financièrement
celui qui a été condamné comme proposé
par votre commission des lois ce sont
l'ensemble des obligés alimentaires
qu'il convient de protéger en cas de
crime au sein de la famille
ensuite des propositions concernant
l'indignité successorale la lutte contre
les violences au sein du couple et même
plus largement au sein de la famille se
poursuit sur le plan successoral
la proposition de loi engage une
réflexion sur l'indignité successorale
le conjoint n'est plus légitime a hérité
lorsqu'il a commis des violences graves
envers le défunt ainsi que vous l'avez
également décidé mesdames aussi un tri
ces messieurs les sénateurs dans la loi
du 28 décembre 2019
le port du bracelet anti rapprochement
dispositif qui sera déployée à partir de
septembre 2020 pourra être non seulement
ordonnée par un juge pénal mais aussi
prévues par un juge civil
à cet égard je soutient l'amendement
porté par le groupe arem permettant
d'assurer un suivi efficace de la
personne à protéger lorsque le porter de
bracelet s'approche ou se maintient dans
la zone dangereuse en violation de la
décision civile ordonnance de protection
je me félicite à nouveau du travail
effectué par votre commission qui a
accentué les dispositifs qui à part dont
accepté les dispositions proposées en
les complétant souvent inutilement sur
un certain nombre de points
je partage également votre remarque sur
l'organisation des débats
j'aurais moi aussi préférer un texte
unique mais le projet du député haut
elien pradier est arrivé avant la fin du
grenelle à un moment où de nombreux
points faisait encore l'objet de
concertations parce que ce projet de loi
permettait la mise en oeuvre rapide de
propositions qui faisait déjà l'objet
d'un consensus le gouvernement et la
majorité non pleinement soutenu tout ce
qui peut contribuer en effet à lutter
contre les violences intrafamiliales que
nous combattons en commun ne peut être
que positif grâce à votre engagement et
au travail du gouvernement de premiers
résultats se dessine le nombre de
demande d'ordonnancé de protection est
passé de 3300 2018 à 3930 en 2019 soit
une augmentation de plus de 21% encore
plus importante lorsqu'on relève qu'il y
en avait que deux 1975 en 2016 il reste
cependant beaucoup à faire encore plus
significatif encore probablement mais ce
même s'il convient d'être extrêmement
prudent on déplore à ce stade
trente six homicides conjugaux en 2020
contre 150 sur l'ensemble de l'année
2019 ce n'est évidemment pas une
victoire et nous ne saurions en aucun
cas nous satisfaire de ces chiffres
toujours glaçant mais cette diminution
du nombre de faits constatés et sans
doute un marqueur de la pertinence des
dispositifs qui ne sont pas encore
totalement déployée mais que nous avons
construit ensemble et mises en oeuvre
ces éléments je le crois donne de
l'espoir et renforce notre volonté c'est
bien en ce sens qu'il faut continuer à
travailler ensemble et pour cela je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre madame marlène
schiappa secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre chargé de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et de la
lutte contre les discriminations vous
avez la parole madame la présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice charles nicole
belloubet madame la sénatrice chars
marie mercier
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs des professionnels des
associations des familles se mobilisent
de long
date contre les violences conjugales et
heureusement depuis quelques années on
observe que cette mobilisation va au
delà des sphères militante qui
habituellement lutte contre les
violences conjugales
la société se réveille enfin médias
politiques citoyens aient fini par
rejeter massivement ces faits que l'on
appelle enfin par leur nom les
féminicides c'est la raison pour
laquelle dès 2017 le président de la
république a décidé de faire de
l'égalité femmes-hommes la grande cause
de son quinquennat et d'agir sur ces
questions les associations de longue
date étaient mobilisés pour demander au
gouvernement d'organiser un grenelle des
violences conjugales
le gouvernement a considéré qu'il était
temps de rassembler les personnes qui
travaillaient jusque là parfois
séparément dans la lutte contre les
violences conjugales les personnels
soignants la police la gendarmerie
le monde de la justice les associations
les familles de victimes
plusieurs d'entre vous ont d'ailleurs
participé à cette occasion au grenelle
des violences conjugales et se sont
réunis à matignon le 3 9 19 date choisie
en référence à la ligne d'écouté du 39
19 pour mieux la faire connaître
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
alors lancé un travail inédit à matignon
composé de onze groupes de travail pour
formuler des propositions sur des
thématiques aussi variées que les
violences intrafamiliales l'éducation la
santé la sphère professionnelle les
outre-mer le handicap
l'accueil en commissariat et en
gendarmerie l'hébergement la justice les
violences psychologiques et l'emprise et
enfin les violences économiques et
pendant trois mois ces groupes de
travail et bien se sont réunis et ont
avancé ensemble pour trouver des
solutions pour mieux protéger les femmes
face aux violences conjugales mieux
prévenir ces violences conjugales mieux
sanctionner leurs auteurs et éviter que
nous continuions simplement à battre le
décompte des féminicides connu par 9 %
seulement de la population avant le
grenelle des violences conjugales grâce
à la mobilisation collective le numéro
du 39 19 est désormais connue par plus
de 65% de la population
le 25 novembre dernier à l'occasion de
la journée internationale pour
l'élimination des violences à l'égard
des femmes
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
annoncé les mesures retenues par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du grenelle
des violences conjugales l'ensemble des
propositions restitués fin octobre par
les responsables des groupes ont été à
leur reprise par le gouvernement et ce
grenelle des violences conjugales a
donné lieu à plus d'une cinquantaine de
mesures de politiques publiques
certaines ne relève pas de la loi
directement certaines relèvent de la loi
et elles sont devenues ou deviendront
réalité grâce aux deux propositions de
loi évoquée à l'instant par nicole
belloubet la première vous la connaissez
vous l'avez débattue elle a été adoptée
à l'initiative du député les
républicains aurélien pradié et la
seconde de nous allons débattre que vous
avez travaillé qui a été voté à
l'assemblée nationale à l'initiative des
députés la république en marge bérengère
couillard et guillaume bouffier chat
comme nous disions précédemment cette
mobilisation collective de la société
civile des experts des préfets des élus
a permis de travailler des mesures
concrètes dont certaines ont crié fait
immédiatement pour agir contre les
violences conjugales
par exemple avec ernestine ronai et avec
les associations nous avons mis en place
une grille d'évaluation du danger que
nous avons présentés avec le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner cette
grille elle s'accompagne d'une nouvelle
formation d'une durée de 120 heures en
formation initiale pour les policiers et
pour les gendarmes afin que les femmes
soient mieux accueilli encore dans les
commissariats et dans les brigades de
gendarmerie
par ailleurs les coûts des victimes est
primordiale et je voudrais remercier ici
l'ordre des médecins pour son engagement
dans cette libération de l' écoute et
tous les professionnels de santé plus
généralement qui suspecte ray un danger
immédiat pour leur patiente parce
qu'avec les dispositions prévues dans
cette proposition de loi
ils pourront désormais signaler mieux
les violences conjugales subies par des
victimes et parfois peut-être leur
sauver la vie
on entend souvent dire que une femme
meurt sous les coups de son conjoint
tous les trois jours
en réalité lorsqu'on étudie sérieusement
les chiffres et les dossiers on
s'aperçoit que le premier mode
opératoire pour les féminicides en
france celle armes à feu c'est pourquoi
il nous a semblé important de saisir ces
armes cela n'évitera pas tous les
féminicides mais cela peut sans doute en
empêcher et alors il faut les empêcher
grâce à cette action du grenelle des
violences conjugales grâce à ses
nouvelles
position législatives les policiers les
gendarmes pourront désormais saisir les
armes des auteurs de violence dès le
dépôt de plainte pour empêcher ces
féminicide comme l'a rappelé la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet dont je
voudrais ici saluer l'engagement total
contre les violences conjugales et pour
protéger les femmes nous aurons à
déployer le nouveau dispositif des
filières de l'urgence pour que les
affaires de violences conjugales soient
traitées plus rapidement et plus
efficacement
enfin la société tout entière commence
véritablement à prendre en compte la
situation des enfants dans les cas de
violence conjugale et avec le secrétaire
d'état chargé de la protection de
l'enfance adrien taquet qui nous
rejoindra nous portons ces mesures de
protection des enfants notamment ceux
qui prévoient d'aménager l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale et je sais à quel
point elle vous tiennent à coeur madame
la sénatrice chère marie mercier ce
texte vous propose également de
décharger les descendants de leurs
obligations alimentaires envers le
parent condamné comme cela est demandé
d'ailleurs depuis des années par
différentes associations
le terreau des violences conjugales
c'est un phénomène de domination d'un
membre du couple sur l'autre et pour la
première fois il vous est proposé de
faire entrer la notion d'entreprise dans
la loi je voudrais donc ici saluer
notamment le travail et l'engagement de
l'ex avocate yaël mellul qui a piloté ce
groupe de travail et qui a oeuvré pour
faire en sorte que ce que l'on appelle
entre guillemets le suicide forcé soit
reconnue désormais comme une
circonstance aggravante
quand nous avons lancé le grenelle des
violences conjugales certaines voix se
sont élevées pour dire que l'état
n'avait pas encore engagé de vraies
politiques de prise en charge des
auteurs de violences conjugales avec la
garde des sceaux nous avons écouté ses
voix nous avons décidé de travailler sur
cette question
nous avons donc décidé d'ouvrir d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
deux centres de prise en charge des
auteurs de violences conjugales par
région nous avons d'ores et déjà lancé
un appel à projet et plusieurs
territoires ayant répondu nous
souhaitons que dans chaque territoire on
puisse prendre en charge les auteurs de
violences conjugales comme ça se fait
déjà à arras pour faire baisser la
récidive parce que prendre en charge les
auteurs c'est diminuer la récidive et
donc c'est in fine et protéger les
femmes face aux violences conjugales
nous avons également pendant le
confinement pris l'initiative de créer
un numéro de téléphone avec la fnac ave
la fédération national d'accompagnement
des auteurs de violences conjugales
pour que les hommes qui se sont avoir
des a
ça de colère qu'ils sentent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas gérer leur accès de violence
puissent être écoutés puissent être pris
en charge et bénéficient d'un
accompagnement psychologique je vous
l'annonçais d'ailleurs cette ligne
d'écouté est en train de passer la barre
des 500 appels depuis sa mise en oeuvre
le 6 avril avec la garde des sceaux nous
l'affirmons l'éviction du conjoint
violent est fondamentale et grâce à la
mise en oeuvre d'une plateforme
d'hébergement spécifique avec le groupe
sos et en lien avec les parquets les
conjoints sont désormais éloignée en
moins de trois heures contre 48 heures
auparavant et une centaine d'auteurs ont
d'ores et déjà depuis le début du
confinement était écarté du domicile
grâce à cette mobilisation et ce
partenariat
c'est notre priorité mettre fin à la
cohabitation entre l'agresseur et la
victime sortir l'homme violent du foyer
ou mettre à l'abri toutes les femmes qui
en ont besoin
c'est pourquoi une charte a été signée
le 27 novembre dernier entre les haies
cia ou le 39 19 pour mieux coordonner
les recherches d'hébergement dédié et de
nouvelles places ouvertes avec le
grenelle des violences conjugales et
l'amener sénatrice mais sur les
sénateurs ces quelques mesures phares du
grenelle des violences conjugales sont
complétés par dizaines d'autres qui font
l'objet d'un suivi rigoureux et régulier
dans leur application et dans leurs
déploiements
c'est à cet effet ce matin que j'ai
réunis à matignon les pilotes des 11
groupes de travail du grenelle des
violences conjugales qui poursuivent
leurs efforts et je tiens à les en
remercier et à saluer les efforts
entrepris par l'ensemble des
administrations dans la bonne
réalisation des mesures en coordination
avec l'ensemble des ministères concernés
et le service des droits des femmes et
de l'égalité grâce à leur implication je
voudrais partager avec vous qu'un tiers
des mesures du grenelle des violences
conjugales est d'ores et déjà réalisé un
autre tiers est en cours de déploiement
et le dernier tiers poursuit sa
préparation notamment en ce moment même
ici avec vous avant de pouvoir être
déployé le continent a été une épreuve
collective qui est venu percuter
l'histoire personnelle et familiale de
chacun et vous le savez il ya eu cinq
fois plus de signalements de violences
conjugales sur le portail
arrêtons les violences point gouv.fr et
36% de signalements en plus auprès des
forces de l'ordre nous nous sommes
mobilisés et la magistrate
elisabeth moiron bros nous remettra en
juillet les résultats de sa mission sur
l'évaluation de la prévalence des
violences conjugales pendant confinement
nous notons d'ores et déjà que s'il ya
eu davantage de signalements il y aurait
eu je parle au conditionnel et avec
prudence mais il y aurait eu moins de
féminicide qu'habituellement je voudrais
également ici remercier les partenaires
privés pour leur engagement auprès des
associations puisque des partenariats
nous ont permis d'ouvrir 90 points
d'écouté d'orientation avec les
associations pour les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales je pense par
exemple aussi notamment au centre
d'entraînement du club de foot de l'om
qui a été un exemple d'engagement
pendant le confinement en mettant ses
locaux et une partie de son personnel à
disposition pour loger les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales en
partenariat avec les services de l'état
vous le savez le signalement par sms au
114 a été rendue possible et nous avons
créé un fonds d'urgence d'un million
d'euros afin de soutenir davantage les
associations et de pouvoir également
financer 20 00h tu es pour les victimes
de violences conjugales
je voudrais pour finir saluer ici
l'engagement des parlementaires de tous
les bords pour mener à bien ses travaux
lors de la tenue du grenelle des
violences conjugales vous êtes
nombreuses et nombreux sur ses bancs
avoir participé aux quelques 180
événements locaux qui se sont tenues
partout en france et qui ont réuni plus
de 4500 personnes
je voudrais particulièrement si vous me
le permettez remercier les sénatrices et
les sénateurs de la commission des lois
madame la sénatrice marie mercier et les
sénatrices et les sénateurs de la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat pour les enrichissements qu'ils
ont pu apporter au texte même si
peut-être nous nous retrouverons pas sur
tous les amendements de la commission
je pense qu'il est heureux de constater
que ensemble nous poursuivons le même
but lutter contre les violences
conjugales et ne rien laisser passer
pour cela mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est
maintenant à madame marie mercier
rapporteur de la commission des lois
vous avez dix minutes
chers collègues merci madame la
présidente mesdames les ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
mes chers collègues encore et toujours
encore me direz-vous encore une loi sur
les violences conjugales est toujours
toujours tant de violence trente six
femmes ont été tuées par le conjoint
depuis le début de l'année
aussi quelques mois seulement après la
promulgation de la loi visant à agir
compter violence au sein de la famille
porté par le député aurélien pradié le
sénat ait saisi une proposition de loi
visant à protéger les victimes des
violences conjugales présenté par deux
députés de la majorité
dérangère couillard et guillon bouficha
ce nouveau texte a pour ambition
d'inscrire dans la loi certaines
préconisations du grenelle contre les
violences conjugales dont les
conclusions ont été rendues publiques le
25 novembre dernier
il comporte aussi des mesures visant à
protéger les mineurs ou à prévenir les
violences en général sur le plan de la
méthode la commission regrette que deux
textes se soit ainsi succédé à quelques
mois d'intervalle l'examen d'un texte
unique déposée après grenelle nous
aurait permis d'avoir un débat plus
cohérent avec une vision globale de la
politique de lutte contre les violences
conjugales et intrafamiliales
le calendrier qui nous a été imposée n'a
pas non plus faciliter notre travail
nous avons été informés il ya juste deux
semaines que ce texte serait examiné
aujourd'hui en séance publique ce qui ne
laissait peu de temps pour achever notre
cycle d'auditions qui était suspendu
pendant la période de confinement je
regrette d'ailleurs de ne pas avoir pu
procéder à une véritable évaluation de
l'impact de ce confinement sur les
violences intrafamiliales
même si nous savons madame les hmida
ménisque voudrais parler d'augmentation
de sainte foy fincke et signalements de
violences conjugales ne même pas pu
apprécier non plus l'efficacité des
dispositifs mis en place pour les
combattre je sais que la délégation aux
droits des femmes de sa vie sa
présidente
à ce moment mené un travail de veille
sur ce sujet au cours des trois derniers
mois ce qui nous permettra de disposer
bientôt deux premiers éléments
d'information très pertinents sur le
fond la commission accueille
favorablement la plupart des mesures qui
figurent dans cette ppl
il me semble toutefois que l'on approche
un peu les limites de ce qu'il est
possible de faire en matière législative
l'arsenal juridique étant déjà très
étoffé
beaucoup de dispositions du texte
consiste en des ajustements des
clarifications des précisions que nous
n'avons pas de raison de refuser mais
qui ne nous semble pas non plus de
nature à renforcer de manière
significative la lutte contre les
violences conjugales
le texte propose tout d'abord
d'interdire le recours à la médiation
pénale et à la médiation familiale en
cas de violences au sein du couple
il parachève ainsi une évolution entamée
il ya plusieurs années qui a déjà
beaucoup restreint le recours à la
médiation
elle ne peut à l'évidence constituer une
procédure adaptée
de violences au sein du couple en raison
de l'inégalité entre l'agresseur et sa
victime
plusieurs articles visite ensuite à
alourdir les peines encourues ou à créer
de nouvelles infractions des
circonstances aggravantes introduites
pour certains délits quand les faits
sont commis par le conjoint ou le
concubin ou le partenaire de pacs
le délit de harcèlement du conjoint
serait puni plus sévèrement
lorsque le harcèlement conduit au
suicide de la victime ce qui n'est pas
rare il est également prévu de compléter
le code pénal pour sanctionner au titre
des atteintes à la vie privée le fait de
géolocaliser un individu sans son
consentement
ces sanctions pénales seraient complétés
par ce qui s'apparente à de nouvelles
formes de sanctions civiles
une disposition porte ainsi sur la
décharge d'obligation alimentaire
elle répond à une demande forte des
associations qui veulent éviter que les
enfants dont par exemple le père a tué
la mère soit contraint de subvenir aux
besoins de leur père meurtrier
la commission a cependant revu la
rédaction craignons qu'une décharge
automatique pose un problème sur le plan
constitutionnel et elle a proposé que ce
soit le juge pénal qui statue sur cette
question dès l'étape de la condamnation
le texte prévoit également que le juge
pourra déclarer indigne de succéder
celui qui a été condamné à une peine
criminelle pour avoir commis des
violences ouen viol sur son conjoint
sur ce point la commission élargie la
liste des infractions permettant de
prononcer une indignité successorale
d'autres dispositions du texte
s'inscrivent davantage dans une démarche
de prévention
je citerai la possibilité donnée au juge
pénal dans le cadre d'un placement sous
contrôle judiciaire de suspendre le
droit de visite et d'hébergement de
l'enfant mineur ou encore l'inscription
d'un plus grand nombre de personnes dans
le fichier
l'objectif étant d'éviter que ces
personnes ne soient embauchés pour des
postes où elle serait placée au contact
des mineurs
certaines mesures longuement débattu au
cours du grenelle se révèle d'une portée
plus limitée
il en est ainsi de l'article 900 la
saisie des sommes que peut posséder le
conjoint violent
la saisie est déjà autorisé pratiqué au
cours des enquêtes et la ppl vie
seulement rendre plus lisible le cadre
juridique applicable
ce n'est pas inintéressant mais ce n'est
pas non plus révolutionnaire même
remarque concernant la possibilité de
déroger au secret médical pour finale et
des faits de violences conjugales
même en l'absence d'accord de la victime
un examen attentif montrent que cette
dérogation vis des hypothèses très
restrictif il faut à la fois un danger
immédiat pour la victime et l'emprise
nous y reviendrons lors des débats pour
lesquels il est déjà admis que le
professeur desanti puisse déroger au
secret
médical au nom de l'obligation de porter
secours à une personne en péril
lajoux qui nous est proposé poursuit
donc surtout avec pédagogique
destination des professionnels de santé
il cherche à attirer leur attention sur
la situation des femmes victimes de
violence conjugale au risque cependant
de rendre plus complexe des exceptions
secret professionnel qui ne sont
toujours pas lisible j'en arrive à
l'article 11 sur l'accès des mineurs aux
sites pornographiques qui a pour objet
de codifier une jurisprudence ans ancien
de la cour de cassation et qui ne
modifie donc pas l'état du droit en
vigueur
la question du contrôle effectif de
l'accès des mineures à ces sites
constituent pourtant un problème majeur
il n'est pas rare aujourd'hui que les
mineurs et taxe est assise contenu
pornographique dès le collège lorsque
les parents leur confient leurs premiers
smartphones ça me faisait penser à
flaubert qui écrit à louise coller le 8
octobre 1852 il lui écrit plus
l'humanité se perfectionne et plus
l'homme se dégrade
il avait déjà bien raison on ne peut
donc le s'inquiéter des conséquences que
l'exposition précoce à ces images peut
entraîner sur leur développement
psychologique et affectif et sur les
relations entre garçons et filles
j'étais donc peu satisfaite du manque
d'ambition de la proposition de loi sur
ce sujet mais le court délai dont nous
allons disposer pour l'étudier ne
m'avait pas permis d'approfondir cette
question avant son examen en commission
donc suivant une démarche un peu
inhabituel et je m'en excuse auprès de
mes collègues de la commission des lois
j'ai procédé à quelques auditions
complémentaires au cours de cette
dernière semaine afin de pouvoir
proposer au sénat un dispositif
réellement à la hauteur des enjeux
m'inspirant d'une mesure en vigueur
depuis dix ans relative aux jeux en
ligne je vous propose de confier au
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel à ce
rôle de régulation en lui donnant le
pouvoir de saisir la justice pour
qu'elle ordonne le blocage de l'accès
aux sites qui ne prendrait aucune mesure
effective pour contrôler l'âge de ceux
qui consultent leurs contenus je crois
que seul le recours à des mesures
réellement dissuasives et susceptibles
d'inciter les éditeurs de ces sites à
agir
en proposant cet amendement je m'inscris
dans la perspective tracée par le
président de la république dans son
discours devant l'unesco le 20 octobre
de 20 novembre dernier il avait alors
donné six mois aux acteurs concernés
pour trouver des solutions sur une base
volontaire
sans quoi le président estimé qu'il
serait nécessaire de légiférer
six mois plus tard le dossier n'a pas
vraiment avancé et le gouvernement n'a
pas encore dévoilé ses intentions
il est donc nécessaire que la
représentation nationale 106 hills et
c'est ce que nous allons faire j'en
termine en évoquant quelques mesures qui
déborde le cadre de la lutte contre les
violences conjugales
nous n'avons pas été convaincus par les
mesures envisagées concernant l'accès
provisoire à l'aide juridictionnelle
dans les procédures d'urgence qui nous a
paru présenter plus d'inconvénients que
davantage mais nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir au cours de la discussion
des amendements
la commission a en revanche approuvé les
dispositions relatives au droit pour les
victimes de violences de se voir
remettre un certificat médical de même
que celle qui ouvre la possibilité de
prononcer certaines interdictions
complément d'une peine d'emprisonnement
ou encore la création de nouvelles
infractions pour mieux sanctionner le
comportement odieux qui consiste à
commanditer depuis la france des crimes
ou des délits commis à l'étranger afin
de les visionner sur internet
en conclusion je voudrais souligner que
nous avons certes besoin de bonnes lois
pour lutter efficacement contre les
violences commises contre les femmes
contre les enfants mais que nous avons
aussi besoin d'une volonté politique
implacable
nous avons besoin de moyens nous avons
besoin de sentir que c'est une priorité
absolue d'éducation et de prévention
l'état doit soutenir tous ceux policiers
gendarmes magistrats éducateurs
travailleurs sociaux association qui
oeuvre aux côtés des victimes mais aussi
aux côtés des auteurs pour les aider à
prendre conscience de leurs actes et
prévenir la récidive
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons faire
vivre cet objectif qui nous rassemble et
qui est au coeur de notre pacte
républicain la protection des plus
fragiles protéger les femmes et les
enfants c'est accepter de changer les
mentalités c'est infléchir ce monde de
violence
nous devons être tous ensemble des têtes
de violence je vous l'avais déjà dit
mais je veux le redire encore la
violence empêche de vivre
elle empêche tout simplement de vivre
merci madame la rapporteure ta parole
est maintenant à madame annick billon
président de la délégation aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes et vous
avez cinq minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues je tiens à
remercier sincèrement marque
madame la rapporteure chère marie
mercier ainsi que la commission des lois
pour leur travail
il ya seulement sept mois nous
débattions d'une proposition de loi
visant à agir contre les violences au
sein de la famille je m'interrogeais
alors sur un calendrier contestable qui
n'ont conduisait à débattre d'un texte
alors que les conclusions du grenelle de
lutte contre les violences conjugales
n'était pas connue
je déplore vivement que la lutte contre
les violences alimente l'inflation
législative son père met un vrai débat
parlementaire
cet empilement de textes disparates n'a
qu'un mérites relatifs celui de faire
des violences un sujet régulier de
l'agenda parlementaire
au risque parfois de voir sortir des
décrets qui vont à l'encontre des
objectifs poursuivis
exemple celui du 27 mai dernier synonyme
du recul des droits des victimes et
contre lequel les avocats spécialisés
s'élève à juste titre je me félicite que
les dispositions de la proposition de
loi met en oeuvre des recommandations
que la délégation aux droits des femmes
portent parfois depuis longtemps
notamment la nécessité absolue
d'interdire toute médiation pénale en
cas de violence ou encore la remise en
question de l'autorité parentale pour un
conjoint violent qui par définition ne
peut être un bon parent certaines
dispositions auraient pu aboutir lors de
la discussion de la loi promulguée en
décembre 2019 des amendements défendus
dans notre hémicycle le permettait
écarté au sénat ils ont pourtant fait
partie des annonces du gouvernement
trois semaines plus tard lors des
conclusions du grenelle en matière de
violence conjugale de nombreuses
avancées aurait pu être franchie depuis
longtemps
car les bonnes pratiques en la matière
sont connus il est difficile de
comprendre que sur les 88 homicides
conjugaux analysées par le rapport de
l'inspection générale de la justice
publiée en octobre 2019
une seule victime et bénéficier d'une
ordonnance de protection
difficile d'accepter que 41 % de ces
femmes est signalé en vain au parquet et
ou aux forces de l'ordre avant d'être
tué des violences ou menaces qu'elle
subissait
difficile d'admettre que sept de ces
meurtres étaient commis malgré une
interdiction d'entrer en contact avec la
victime
difficile enfin de croire que 90% des
femmes victimes de violences aient pu se
déclarer satisfaits de l'accueil reçu
dans les commissariats et gendarmeries
selon l'audit annoncé lors du grenelle
ce n'est absolument pas le constat fait
par les experts entendus par la
délégation la discussion de cette
proposition de loi intervient après
plusieurs semaines de confinement qui
ont rendu difficile la protection de
femmes et d'enfants enfermés dans un
foyer violent pendant ce confinement
notre délégation a centré son travail
sur les violences parmi les lacunes
pointées par les interlocuteurs de la
délégation citons l'insuffisante
interactions entre la police le parquet
et le juge civil
soulignons aussi la nécessité évoquée
par luc frémiot ancien procureur de la
république de douai est d'encadrer plus
strictement l'activité des procureurs en
matière de lutte contre les violences et
d'organiser pour les auteurs de
violences
un suivi psychologique dans la durée le
principal enjeu est d'abord de permettre
aux victimes que le confinement a tenu
éloigné des institutions judiciaires de
porter plainte elles ne doivent plus
recevoir pour toute réponse une main
courante
inutile il est impératif de leur assurer
un accueil adapté sur tous les
territoires en métropole comme dans les
outre-mer nous ne pouvons plus accepter
que les chances d'une victime d'être
crue est prise au sérieux dépendent de
la sensibilisation aux violences
conjugales du professionnel qui va les
accueillir
la responsabilité de l'état pour faute
lourde dans des affaires de violence
ce conjugale comme cela a été le cas à
grande synthe se doit de demeurer une
exception
il y a urgence pour de nombreuses femmes
et de nombreux enfants
le confinement n'est pas terminée la
réalité quotidienne des fans lui mieux
maintenu dans une terreur permanente par
un conjoint ou un père violent ressemble
à un confinement sans fin la priorité
pour nous est de gagner le combat contre
les violences conjugales et de le gagner
tous ensemble
cette proposition de loi y contribuera
tél espérons le
dans chaque commissariat dans chaque
gendarmerie et dans chaque juridiction
toutes les victimes de violence doivent
pouvoir rencontrer des professionnels
acharné à les protéger
ce n'est qu'à cette condition que nous
pourrons gagner ce combat ensemble je
vous remercie
merci madame la présidente quand la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est maintenant à madame marie
pierre de la gontrie pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain vous avez cinq
minutes si un collègue madame la
présidente mesdames les ministres madame
la rapporteure je salue d'ailleurs nos
collègues masculins qui participent à
ces travaux comme à chaque fois que nous
traitons de ce thème très important
nous sommes ici réunis pour un exercice
un peu particulier et d'ailleurs vos
interventions mesdames les ministres
l'ont bien mis en lumière puisque nous
débattons depuis je crois plusieurs mois
mais en tous cas me concernant je suis
élu depuis trois ans et la troisième
reprise
sur la question des violences conjugales
alors on peut de manière très optimiste
comme viennent de le faire ni billon
considérer que ça veut dire que le sujet
préoccupe
en réalité nous savons bien que cela
veut dire que nous légiférons dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas de meilleure
qualité
la preuve étant que cette proposition de
loi dont la génèse est un petit peu
particulière et dont l'examen au fond
traduit la nécessité de réconforter la
majorité en marche qui après le grenelle
avait été fort dépité de constater que
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
aurélien pradié
était très innovante et avait réussi à
rassembler sur des choses sur des
propositions originales des majorités et
donc une proposition de loi fut déposée
en catastrophe
à preuve deux articles ont dû
disparaître puisque nous l'avions déjà
voté et mesdames les ministres vous avez
du tout à leur faire davantage le bilan
de ce que vous avez fait que parler du
texte lui-même alors ce texte mérite ni
excès d'indignité ni excès d'honneur
il améliore de manière assez marginal un
certain nombre de sujets il reprend sur
d'autres des amendements qui avaient
présenté d'ailleurs le groupe socialiste
mais qui n'avait pas eu l'heur de plaire
et finalement va permettre d'avancer
encore un pas supplémentaire mais il est
aussi l'occasion finalement de réparer
une erreur nous avons découvert comme
les associations d'ailleurs que un
décret avait été pris par vous madame la
garde des sceaux le 27 mai dernier qui
avait vocation ni plus ni moins que de
rendre impossible pour la plaignante ou
plutôt pour la demandeuse puisque nous
sommes en matière civile d'engager de
manière réaliste la procédure par
ordonnance de protection
pourquoi parce qu'il fallait avoir
recours à un huissier qu'il fallait
notifié la date d'audience qu'il fallait
ensuite en 24 heures à voir à la fois
notifié puis est retourné auprès du
magistrat j'ai été avocate pendant 17
ans trouvé un ami ici dans la journée et
déjà un tour de force mais pouvoir
lorsqu'on est simple particulier le
trouver
le obtenir qu'ils fassent signifier une
ordonnance et en faire retour devant le
juge je vous le dis c'est impossible et
c'est ce que les associations ont bien
compris en expliquant que ce décret dont
je ne sais s'il est le fruit de
l'incompétence ou du cynisme à vider
totalement la possibilité de produire
l'ordonance de protection dont vous
indiquez que vous y êtes attachés donc
nous avons avec le groupe socialiste
présenté un amendement
je suis heureuse d'avoir convaincu les
collègues de la majorité du sénat et
nous allons pouvoir revenir sur ce point
très problématique décret d'ailleurs
dont je souligne qu'il avait mis cinq
mois à paraître c'est dire si le sujet
était urgent pour la chancellerie
donc au final que dire que sur certains
points nous allons proposer des
amendements évidemment complémentaires
qui sait peut-être convaincre on nous
cette fois sur la question de la
résidence des enfants sur la question
du traitement du conjoint du conjoint du
compagnon violent mais aussi sur les
rôles des magistrats et bien sûr sur la
réception des plaignantes devant les
services de police
un grand absent que nous avons essayé de
faire revenir par le biais d'un demandes
de rapports qui rencontre toujours un
succès qui est quand même proche de zéro
dans cet hémicycle
c'est la question des moyens parce que
nous le savons dans ce sujet s'il n'ya
pas formation accompagnement des
associations aide juridictionnelle nous
le proposerons également conséquente de
manière à ce que les femmes sachent et
de la communication également
sache que l on un arsenal à leur
disposition mais aussi un accompagnement
possible qui permettent de limiter la
violence qu'elles subissent nous
n'obtiendrons rien et nous aurons
finalement voté pour la troisième fois
en quelques mois un texte qui n'aura pas
fait progresser les choses et le sort
des femmes n'aura pas été davantage
protégés nous n'avons pas de retour à ce
jour sur ce qui s'est passé pendant la
période du confinement
j'ai tendance à penser que les chiffres
qui sortent aujourd'hui qui sont de
toute façon dramatique
effectivement madame la garde des sceaux
je partage votre point de vue nous ne
pouvons pas nous réjouir qu'un chiffre
diminue alors même qu'il existe toujours
mais nous aurons je pense la nécessité
d'un retour sur la période du
confinement qui a dû être terrible pour
un certain nombre de familles et y
compris pour des enfants
voilà pourquoi au final ce texte nous le
voterons sans doute mais avec un
enthousiasme assez relatif
étant donnée sa porte et fort limité je
vous remercie mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues 10000 c'est le nombre
d'appels qu'a reçu la plateforme 39 19
durant le confinement la preuve s'il en
fallait une encore du danger que courent
les femmes dans notre société
nous étudions aujourd'hui et cela a été
dit maintes fois le troisième texte en
moins de deux ans sur les violences
faites aux femmes
c'est la preuve que le temps de lutter
contre ce fléau est arrivé c'est positif
parce que cela complète utilement
l'arsenal juridique
dont nous disposons déjà mais cela ne
doit pas masquer que cet arsenal n'est
pas toujours employé du moins
suffisamment employés sur notre
territoire
il est donc temps de passer de la parole
aux actes
pour autant cette proposition de loi
apporte des améliorations et elle se
fait l'écho du grenelle sur les
violences conjugales
certes et cela et dédie également
certains des éléments de ce texte aurait
pu être voté dès le passage de la
proposition de loi pradier certes ce
texte ne reprend pas l'ensemble des
mesures du grenelle il faudra sans doute
un quatrième texte
mais ces propositions de loi apporte des
améliorations on y retrouve par exemple
la saisie des armes des conjoints
violents
l'évolution du secret médical ou encore
la suspension du droit de visite
en cas de suspicion de violence l'auteur
il ya également traités et c'est à
saluer des nouvelles formes de violence
exercée via les nouvelles technologies
ainsi il trouve t'on la pénalisation du
cyber harcèlement entre conjoints ou
encore celle de la géolocalisation non
consenti et à propos de l'informatique
je voudrais souligner l'évolution
apportée par notre rapporteur marie
mercier sur l'inscription au fichage des
individus condamnés pour consultation
des contenus pédopornographiques
nos travaux lors de la mission
d'information sur la pédocriminalité
dans les institutions avaient mis en
évidence le trop peu de cas qu'ils
étaient faits de la consultation
d'imagés pédopornographiques
or cette consultation est souvent le
symptôme d'un mal bien plus profond et
n'oublions pas que l'enfant violet sur
une image ou dans un film est un
véritable enfant véritablement violée
merci donc madame la rapporteure je
salue également dans ce texte la rupture
avec le dogme du lien sacré familiale
ce dogme a longtemps été le credo de
juge aux affaires familiales
on ne sépare pas un enfant de ses
parents comment peut-on penser qu'il
soit nécessaire
pire positif de garder un lien entre le
bourreau et sa victime
je me réjouis donc de voir que
l'obligation alimentaire un cycle droit
de la succession puissent être écartés
en cas de grimm de crime ou de délit
intrafamiliaux ensuite la notion
d'emprise
elle est maintenant reconnue l'emprise
c'est une mare de mazout dans laquelle
on se débat on ne peut s'en sortir seul
il faut l'intervention d'une personne
extérieure pour vous sortir du magma
dans lequel vous est engluée pour vous
aider à nettoyer vos ailes et ensuite
reprendre votre envol l'emprise est
malheureusement souvent la clé de
compréhension des situations de violence
répétés qui peuvent aller jusqu'au
meurtre
enfin autre apport de ce texte la
question du secret médical et la
possibilité pour un médecin d'y déroger
naturellement cette dérogation est
encadrée et la rapporteure apporte des
nuances bienvenue dans la rédaction du
texte pour autant à titre personnel je
défendrai un amendement sur ce sujet car
la notion retenue de danger immédiat
pour la vie d'une victime me semble mal
venu en matière de violence conjugale
lorsqu'une victime fait face un danger
immédiat pour sa vie il est déjà trop
tard et elle se rend alors rarement chez
son médecin de famille c'est aux
urgences qu'on la retrouve dans le
meilleur des cas la notion de danger
tout simplement me semble donc plus
indiqué cette proposition apporte des
améliorations disait mais j'y vois un
bémol tout de même la prévention la
détection le suivi l'évitement de la
récidive
qu'en est il
pourtant ces éléments sont
indispensables si l'on veut éviter et
non lutter contre les violences
conjugales
il est vrai que des mesures ont été
prises dans ce sens récemment le
changement de paradigme par exemple avec
maintenant l'éloignement du conjoint
violent et non plus de la femme et de
ses enfants
la circulaire de madame la garde des
sceaux également rappelant que les
enfants témoins de violences conjugales
sont aussi des victimes et doivent être
représentés à ce titre ou encore le
numéro d'appel mis en place par la fnac
have pour les hommes violents
je me permets de rappeler à cette
occasion que lors de notre rapport sur
la pédocriminalité dans les institutions
marie mercier michel meunier et moi même
un peu lyon de nos voeux un tel numéro
pour les pédophiles pour éviter qu'il ne
devienne pédocriminels il y a encore du
travail donc notamment
et là aussi cela a été dit sur la
formation des professionnels de santé de
l'éducation de la police ou de la
gendarmerie en matière de violence
conjugale et de protection des mineurs
une meilleure formation de ces acteurs
permettrait de détecter le plus en amont
possible ce poison une bonne formation
des policiers et des gendarmes
permettrait de mieux accueillir les
victimes est de proscrire la main
courante pour aller vers un dépôt de
plainte systématique
maintenant je voudrais bien sûr évoquer
les moyens car la bonne intention n'est
pas suffisante
je prends l'exemple des stages pour les
hommes violents une excellente idée sur
le papier mais dans les faits il y a
tellement de peu de place et de
psychologues qu'il faut attendre
plusieurs mois pour en intégrer un qui
ne durera que quelques heures au mieux
quelques jours pensez vous qu'un homme
qui ne communique que par la violence
soient guéris en deux jours ne croyez
vous pas que les six mois d'attentes
pour être traités ne soit pas six mois
d'enfer pour le conjoint violent t mais
je pourrais parler aussi du manque
criant de psychologues dans les
commissariats et les gendarmeries du
manque d'infirmières scolaires de la
baisse des aides aux associations
bref encore beaucoup de besoins à
satisfaire mais bien sûr ce n'est pas
parce que le chemin est long qu'il ne
faut pas le prendre
vous l'aurez compris le groupe union
centriste votre à ce texte
merci sa collègue ta parole est
maintenant à madame laure darcos pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez cinq
minutes
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues le sénat
examine aujourd'hui la proposition de
loi visant à protéger les victimes de
violences conjugales
ce texte s'inscrit dans le prolongement
du grenelle des violences conjugales
ouverte par le gouvernement le 3
septembre dernier et se veut le
complément de la loi du 28 décembre 2019
visant à agir contre les violences au
sein de la famille qui était issu de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
aurélien pradié la loi du 28 décembre
2019 constitue à n'en pas douter une
véritable avancée pour les victimes
avec la possibilité donnée au juge
d'ordonner la pose du bracelet anti
rapprochement
le recours élargi au téléphone grave
danger ou encore le renforcement du
dispositif de l' ordonnance de
protection désormais délivrés plus
rapidement et plus protectrice pour les
victimes
il est par exemple d'une importance
capitale que le conjoint violent puisse
être évincé du domicile conjugal dans
les plus brefs délais cette loi par
ailleurs prévu diverses mesures afin de
faciliter le relogement des victimes de
violences et il faut s'en réjouir car le
logement constitue un élément fondateur
de toute reconstruction personnelle
alors pourquoi ce nouveau texte et y est
pourquoi est il déposait parlement avant
même que la loi de 2019 et démontrer la
pleine mesure de sa capacité à juguler
les violences conjugales et à servir
durablement ses victimes
encore faut-il qu'elles soient suivies
d'effets de films de financements
suffisants pour soutenir les
associations les dispositifs judiciaires
comme le bracelet anti rapprochement
permettez moi d'insister la proposition
de loi pradier était un texte
pragmatique et apportant des solutions
juridiques précises pour preuve deux
dispositions concernant l'autorité
parentale figurants initialement dans le
texte qui nous est soumis il ne reste
pas grand chose la commission des lois
de l'assemblée nationale se résoudre à
constater que la législation en vigueur
traiter cette question de manière
adéquate depuis 2014 la juridiction de
jugement a en effet l'obligation de se
prononcer sur le retrait total ou
partiel de l'autorité parentale de
l'auteur d'un crime ou d'un délit commis
sur la personne de l'autre parent il
s'agit là d'une mesure de protection de
l'enfant qui répond à la tragédie
familiale
il affecte directement néanmoins
décision de retrait de l'autorité
parentale sur le fondement d'infractions
commises sur l'autre parent était
jusqu'ici trop peu nombreuses sans doute
parce que c'est une certaine idée
prévalait selon laquelle l'intérêt de
l'enfant résidait dans le maintien coûte
que coûte des liens familiaux avec
l'auteur des violences
l'apport de la loi du 28 décembre 2010 9
et ici intéressante à plus d'un titre
celle ci permet désormais aux
juridictions civiles et pénales qui ont
la faculté de prononcer le retrait total
ou partiel de l'autorité parentale de
prononcé alternativement le retrait
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
par ailleurs elle a prévu une suspension
de plein droit de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale pour six mois afin
de libérer l'enfant de la tutelle de
l'auteur du crime dans l'attenté d'une
décision pérenne de l'institution
judiciaire
ces dispositions devraient rapidement
faire preuve de leur efficacité à
préserver l'intégrité physique et morale
des enfants au regard d'une opinion
publique tolérante de moins en moins les
violences intrafamiliales et la
persistance d'une certaine domination de
la figure paternelle
et ce sont justement les enfants
particulièrement vulnérables qu'il nous
faut sans relâche protéger des dérives
des adultes des adultes
notre délégation aux droits des femmes
dont je salue la vigilance constante sur
tous ces sujets a mené de nombreuses
auditions sur le thème des violences
intrafamiliales
tous nos interlocuteurs ont attesté les
conséquences souvent dramatiques de ces
violences sur la construction
identitaire des enfants les enfants sont
d'autant plus fragilisée que les faits
de violence sont répétés s'aggraver
s'inscrit dans un rapport de force
asymétrique
leur impact est variable selon le degré
d'exposition à la violence conjugale
mais aussi selon l'âge de l'enfant et
son sexe certains experts évoquent un
syndrome de stress post traumatique
pouvant être accompagnés d'effets
négatifs avec temps le développement de
l'enfant ces conduites fonctionnement
cognitif et émotionnelle perturbé santé
dégradé problèmes d'échec scolaire
démonstration d'agressivité et usage de
la violence à l'âge adulte ces enfants
exposés présente un risque bien réel de
reproduire les comportements violents
dont ils ont été témoins toute politique
publique doit donc chercher des
solutions permettant de favoriser la
résilience
c'est pourquoi la proposition de loi
visant à protéger les victimes de
violences conjugales que nous examinons
aujourd'hui elle semble comporter une
mesure importante au regard de cet
objectif
la possibilité donnée au juge suspendent
droit de visite et d'hébergement dont
une personne placée sous contrôle
judiciaire est titulaire cette
possibilité n'était pas prévu par la loi
2019 le juge pouvant seulement prononcé
à l'encontre de l'auteur des faits dans
le cadre du contrôle judiciaire une
interdiction de s'approcher de la
victime et de paraître domicile au
domicile ou aux abords immédiats de
celui ci
l'exercice du droit de visite et
d'hébergement est en effet un moment
particulièrement redouté par les
victimes de violences conjugales
permettre au juge d'instruction et au
juge des libertés et de la détention de
redonner à ce stade de la procédure
pénale la suspension du droit de visite
et d'hébergement à l'égard des enfants
est une mesure indispensable complétant
utilement le dispositif de protection
des victimes
je la soutiens donc totalement
permettez-moi toutefois au terme de
cette intervention de former un voeu il
est temps me semble-t-il de mettre un
terme à cette inflation législative et
de laisser l'ensemble des acteurs et en
particulier ceux de la chaîne pénale se
saisir des nouveaux outils à leur
disposition pour combattre le fléau des
violences conjugales
je vous remercie merci sa collègue
la parole est maintenant la dame
laurence rossignol pour le socialiste et
républicain et vous avez cinq minutes
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
ministres madame la rapporteure et
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois devrait d'abord en quelques
mots rendre hommage aux militantes
féministes à ses activistes à ces femmes
souvent raillée et moquée caricaturée
dans l'histoire de notre société sans
qui on ne parlerait probablement
toujours pas des violences conjugales ou
on considérerait toujours qu'il s'agit
là d'une affaire privée et en aucun cas
d'un sujet politique
il faut leur rendre hommage parce que
nous n'en avons pas fini encore avec la
compréhension collective et l'action
publique contre les violences
intrafamiliales les violences faites aux
femmes et aux enfants et je voudrais
dire d'abord parce qu'il ya aucun
suspense que le groupe socialiste votera
je n'ose pas appeler ça une oie j'invite
bien votre à les articles ce sont des
articles ce n'est pas réellement une loi
et cette manière de construire la loi
certes elle est historique la première
loi sur les violences faites aux femmes
doit dater de 92 je dirais celle qui
reconnaît le meurtre par conjoint comme
une circonstance aggravante compter
comme première loi sur la prise en
compte des violences intrafamiliales des
violences conjugales
et quand on retrace l'histoire de la loi
pour sanctionner et prévenir les
violences faites aux femmes
on observe que ce n'est pas une loi
c'est une addition permanente de
nouvelles lois de nouveaux articles
glisser dans un texte dans un autre ce
qui d'ailleurs ont faim et vite un
édifice juridique qui est loin d'être
parfait et on voit comment à chaque fois
c'est le parlement souvent ou une
ministre qui a voulu ainsi ré quelque
chose supplémentaire
et malheureusement la loi que nous
votons aujourd'hui ne rompt pas avec ce
mode de construction et surtout elle
n'en finit pas il y aura encore d'autres
lois par la suite pour prévenir et
réprimer les violences faites aux femmes
je vous réponds n'a pas regretté deux
choses la première c'est que ce mode de
construction
il sépare ils segmente les différentes
dimensions de la condition des femmes et
nous aurions aimé
nous aurions voulu puisqu'il y avait
grande cause du quinquennat donc un
avantage puisque à une mobilisation de
la société comme il n'a jamais eu à la
fois il ya mis tout mais surtout liée
aussi aux médias qui reconnaissons lui
ont fait un travail qu'il n'avait jamais
fait auparavant pour porter sur la scène
publique et violences faites aux femmes
nous aurions aimé une grande loi contre
les violences faites aux femmes une
grande loi qui rend glb est à la fois
les violences économiques et ce n'est
pas les progrès que vous avez fait sur l
agence région larripa l'argence de
recouvrement des impayés de pension
alimentaire dont je déplore par ailleurs
que vous ayez accepté que la mise en
oeuvre soit reporté de six mois ce qui
prouve que
dans le confinement les femmes ont beau
être les premières victimes elles sont
aussi les victimes du confinement des
administrations une violence et violence
économique les violences sexuelles les
droits sexuels et reproductifs
parce que lorsqu'on fait comme vous
l'avez fait pendant ces deux mois
d'opposer un refus systématique d'un
allongement de deux semaines des der
heydt ivg on accroît les violences
faites aux femmes ne pas pouvoir avorter
est une violence faite aux femmes
et cette violence là vous l'avez assumer
sur deux vous au gouvernement et en même
temps en même temps vous venez
régulièrement dans le parlement avec des
propositions de loi vous auriez pu aussi
un cri inclure une loi anti sexistes
peut-être nous en ont également bien
besoin
bref une vraie loi permettant de
transformer et de changer la condition
des femmes et ne comptant pas uniquement
sur la société sa mobilisation mais
comptant sur l'appui politique et
l'appui des pouvoirs publics ce qui me
fait dire que nous y reviendront
probablement c'est que en ce qui
concerne la dimension extrêmement
mortifère pour les femmes des violences
post séparation elle n'est toujours pas
suffisamment prises en compte
en fait ce texte ne rompt pas avec une
coutume de la chancellerie qui consiste
à penser qu'il ne faut pas se mêler de
l'office du juge est en fait plus on
laisse juge libre et en particulier à la
justice civile 1 h 6 familiale plus on
multiplie les occasions que la
séparation souhaite une occasion de
violence pour les femmes
et là encore nous aurons des amendements
tout à l'heure qui viseront non pas à
tenir la main du juge mais simplement
indiqué seul et quelles sont les
matières que le juge de la traiter à
chaque fois et puis quelles sont les
questions qui doit se poser avant de
rendre son ordonnance pas simplement
dans une protection de ces ordonnances
de divorce et probablement vous nous
répondre et qu'il faut laisser le juge
libre or le juge ça n'existe pas dans la
vraie vie c'est un concept de
d'étudiants en droit mais dans la vraie
vie à des quantités de juges et des
femmes maltraitées par la justice civile
madame la garde des sceaux vous avez la
parole pour répondre aux héros attristé
orateurs des différents groupes
politiques
merci les dames la présidente je ne
souhaite pas répondre à l'ensemble des
orateurs que je remercie ici tantôt des
observations tantôt même des
propositions j'ai notamment entendu ce
qui était dit sur la formation des
policiers des magistrats qui est déjà à
l'oeuvre avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
volontarisme
je voudrais simplement ici évoqué un
point qu'a soulevé madame la sénatrice
de la gontrie
à propos du décret du 28 mai dernier
dont l'objet était d'assurer la mise en
oeuvre des ordonnances de protection
dans le cadre qui a été voulu par la loi
pradier je vous rappelle que depuis la
loi du 28 décembre dernier
vous avez décidé et le gouvernement
évidemment applique la loi que ces
ordonnances de protection devait être
délivré dans un délai de 6 jours
notre objectif premier est vous le savez
madame la sénatrice s'est bien entendu
de multiplier la délivrance des
ordonnances de protection parce que nous
considérons que c'est un outil qui peut
être un outil juridique qui peut être
extrêmement protecteur pour les femmes
et donc nous avons mis en place un texte
pour assurer que ces ordonnances de
protection puisse effectivement être
délivré dans les six jours de fixation
de la date de l'audience est dense et
six journées là nous devons également
assurer le respect du principe du
contradictoire et donner la possibilité
aux défendeurs de faire valoir ses
droits
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
installé un délai qui est un délai de 24
heures qui a été donné pour informer le
défendeur je suis très simple et très
clair avec vous dès demain la haute
fonctionnaire à l'égalité femmes hommes
de mon ministère réunit des
professionnels
elle va également réunir les
associations qui sont concernés et comme
je voulais dis-je met en place un comité
de pilotage de suivi de l'ordonance de
protection je n'ai aucune difficulté à
prendre en compte les succès et les
suggestions qui pourraient mettre
formuler les rectifications qui
apparaîtrait nécessaire et évidemment
si celle ci semble judicieuse dans le
respect du principe du contradictoire je
rectifierai le texte rapidement et sans
hésitation
mon seul souci c'est l'effectivité de la
délivrance des ordonnances de protection
cet amendement a vocation à revenir sur
ce décret dont nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure les effets contre-productifs
décret qui a été pris par la
chancellerie
le 27 mai dernier en application d'une
disposition de la loi du 28 décembre de
l'année précédente
comme vous le savez je rappelle je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure rapidement lorsqu'une
femme je fais ça de manière un peu
simple je dis que c'est une femme
lorsqu'une femme décide de faire la
démarche de demander une ordonnance de
protection
elle va voir un juge pour obtenir une
date pour que cette demande soit
examinée de manière contradictoire et
lorsque le juge rend cette ordonnance
qui fixe la date d'examen
contradictoires cette femme doit dans
les 24 heures
notifié cette ordonnance de dates qui
vaut convocation à son adversaire
en clair à la personne qui la maltraite
et ensuite ramené la preuve de cette
notification aux juges
elle a 24 heures pour le faire et si
elle ne fait pas ça dans les 24 heures
la requête est caduque
que se passe-t-il dans la réalité il
faut donc qu'elle fasse appel à un
huissier puisqu'il ya trois voies de
notification dans le dans le code
la première c'est aussi pâle
hiérarchique mais c'est là le recommandé
avec accusé de réception nous sommes
dans un délai de 6 jours évidemment
c'était pas possible
la deuxième c'est la voie administrative
c'est à dire un officier de police ou un
gendarme dépose la convocation remet la
convocation
la troisième c'est l'huissier lui si il
faut le trouver il faut qu'il accepte et
ça coûte cher et ensuite qui vous
rendent l'acte et que vous puissiez le
porter bref cette disposition prévue au
décret la mine totalement toute
possibilité
mener cette procédure dans des délais
qui lui permettent ensuite d'avoir une
audience puis l' ordonnance de
protection dans les six jours
donc ce qui est proposé ici c'est
quelque chose que nous avions déjà
proposé de la proposition pradier c'est
que ce soit par voie de signification à
la charge du ministère public ou par
voie administrative donc premièrement ce
n'est pas la demandeuse qui payent pas
qu'ils allaient frais deuxièmement c'est
un officier police ou un gendarme qui
remet la convocation et nous résolvons
ainsi la question du délai de 24 heures
qui a évidemment ému beaucoup les
associations de défense les avocats etc
j'ai entendu ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure madame la garde des sceaux et je
pense que du coup vous allez être
sensible à ma proposition puisque vous
avez indiqué vous même et je vous crois
que votre souci c'était qu' il y ait un
recours massif à massifs important aux
ordonnances de protection
si j'ai envie de dire quoi qu'il en
coûte merci merci cher collègue madame
la rapporteure quel est l'avis de la
commission c'est un avis favorable
merci madame la ministre oui c'est un
avis défavorable madame la sénatrice à
votre proposition effectuée vous
l'expliquer défavorable je disais oui
pour les raisons suivantes d'abord sur
le premier point je vous signale juste
simplement que nous avons supprimé la
lettre recommandée avec accusé de
réception
cela figure dans les textes ensuite si
nous pensons qu'il vaut mieux passer par
le avec le concours des huissiers
c'est parce que nous avons est gelée
précisait tout à l'heure nous avons
organisé au sein des tribunaux pour
répondre à l'exigence des six jours
nous avons organisé de manière très
concrète ce que nous appelons les
filières de l'urgence et je le disais
tout à l'heure demain encore nous avons
une réunion de travail qui va permettre
à nouveau de modéliser de travailler sur
ce que sont ces filières de l'urgence et
dans ce cadre là il va de soi que dès
que le juge aura fixé la date de
l'audience alors les associations les
avocats les huissiers qui sont disposés
à org
10 et des permanences auront
immédiatement seront immédiatement
présents pour assurer le relais de la
mise en oeuvre de la signification et
c'est dans cette pratique là telle
qu'elle est autorisée par la loi était
qu'elle découle du décret que nous
estimons utile de proposer le rôle de
ces assignation par huissier de 7,7
signification par huissier
si la voie administrative était imposée
elle monopoliserait les services de
police et les services de gendarmerie
pour délivrer des décisions de justice
qui ne paraît pas nécessairement
opportun dans ce cadre là je pense que
nous pouvons arriver à un résultat de
même nature est aussi efficace en
travaillant donc avec la chambre
nationale des huissiers et avec les
huissiers de justice il me semble
également que si les forces de l'ordre
voie administrative n'arrive pas
notifier la décision au défendeur il ne
dispose pas de la possibilité d'établir
un procès verbal d'absence comme peut le
faire l'huissier de justice et donc les
faits l'impact n'est pas le même ceci
est important enfin dernier point que je
voulais ajouter nous travaillons
également sur la prise en charge par le
biais de l'aide juridictionnelle de ces
frais qui pourraient découler du recours
à l'huissier de justice et c'est donc
l'ensemble d'un processus que nous
mettons concrètement en oeuvre et c'est
donc la raison pour laquelle j'aime et
un avis défavorable à votre proposition
merci madame cohen vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la présidente nous
partageons tout à fait l'argumentaire de
notre collègue madame de la gontrie sur
le sujet il est indéniable que les
nouvelles règles de fonctionnement
fixées par le décret du 27 mai 2020 ce
qui concerne l'obtention d'une
ordonnance de protection représente un
danger pour les victimes de violences
conjugales
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
madame la garde des sceaux nous
proposions également avec notre
amendement numéro 84 jugée recevable en
vertu de l'article 41 que l' ordonnance
soit notifiée aux défendeurs par le
ministère public qu'ils soient ou non à
l'initiative de la requête
alors on est tout à fait conscient de la
difficulté
de légiférer en la matière il s'agissait
tout de même de proposer la
rectification de la notification de
l'ordonnancé de protection en visant un
article du code pénal et non un article
du code de procédure civile lequel est
exclusivement réglementaire monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
c'est vous que j'interpelle si vous
m'entendez je m'étonne de
l'irrecevabilité dont a été frappé notre
amendement alors que le fond du sujet
visait exactement les mêmes
modifications que l'amendement dont nous
discutons à présent l'administration
nous a fait savoir qu'une proposition de
réécriture avait été proposé à nos
collègues socialistes nous nous en
réjouissons
mais nous n'avons pas bénéficié de la
même faveur car notre amendement
reprenait des alinéas du décret
j'entends le sujet mais là cela n'est
pas la première fois que l'application d
irrecevabilité ne joue pas en notre
faveur et il faudra bien à un moment
donné mes chers collègues refaire le
point sur cette pratique pour qu'elle
s'applique dans les mêmes termes quel
que soit le groupe à l'initiative des
propositions d'amendements quoi qu'il en
soit nous soutiendrons l'amendement de
nos collègues socialistes parce que
madame la garde des sceaux et
malheureusement elle est partie les
arguments qui ont été avancés par ses
soins ne nous ont pas convaincus
parce que en même temps si j'ai bien
compris l'accompagnement qu'elle faisait
au niveau de l'aide juridictionnelle par
rapport aux victimes
je trouve que compte tenu de ce que
vivent les victimes ça reporte encore un
poids sur elle puisque ce sont elles qui
doivent faire les démarches
administratives
donc c'est pourquoi nous soutenons
l'amendement de nos collègues et
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
vraiment j'attends avec impatience votre
réponse merci chers collègues qui vous
est donnée par le président bah vous
avez la parole et louis je vous remercie
et chers collègues
c'est tout simple en réalité
confrontés les deux amendements quelles
que soient leurs mérites respectifs sur
le fond celui que vous aviez présenté en
réalité reprenait les termes même d'un
décret c'est assez difficile de ne pas
considérer qu'il intervenait dans le
champ réglementaire de ce fait tandis
que l'autre amendement au lieu de
traiter des modalités d'application de
la loi qui relève du décret se prononcer
sur des principes c'est la raison pour
laquelle la commission a estimé que
votre amendement n'était pas recevable
mais c'est une question qui a trait au
partage des compétences entre le
gouvernement et le législateur ce n'est
pas une appréciation sur les mérites de
votre amendement
merci y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote je n'en vois pas
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 60
rectifié bis avec un avis favorable de
la commission est l'avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adoptée au nom de
la commission des lois
merci merci madame la présidente a alors
c'est un amendement très important je
vais vous présenter maintenant on a déjà
commencé à débattre du sujet que ce soit
sur un ordinateur ou sur leur smartphone
des mineurs peuvent de nos jours très
facilement visionner des contenus
pornographiques disponible gratuitement
en ligne
ils savent le faire très bien il tape le
nom d'un signe et ils ont vignette avec
des propositions d'axés tout de suite au
film porno en violation de la loi de
nombreux sites internet ont renoncé à
mettre en place un véritable contrôle de
l'âge des personnes qu'ils visionnent
ces images il suffit d'un clic par
lequel le mineur certifie avoir plus de
18 ans il est jugé plus de 18 ans pour
que des milliers de vidéos
pornographiques du soin accessible
quelquefois même on ne propose pas avez
vous plus 18 ans quelquefois même c'est
pas proposé pourtant il existe des
solutions d'identification de l'âge par
exemple en passant par france connect ou
en utilisant une carte de paiement
beaucoup de mineurs visionnent ces
images dès leur entrée au collège aux
intercours ce qui conduit à s'interroger
sur l'impact que la consommation d'image
pornographique pour avoir un moyen terme
sur leur développement affectif
psychologique et sexuelle un autre
chiffre
on sait que 50 % des moins de 12 ans ont
déjà visionné un film pornographique
dans sa totalité et que les premières
images porno elle arrive chine m sur
pour des enfants de 7 à 8 ans quand il
regarde un autre film tout d'un coup on
leur bombardent des images
pornographiques à 7 8 ans ils vont pas
forcément s'identifier look à la limite
c'est moins grave que à 12 13 ans bien
que ce soit très grave quand même donc
en principe l'article 227-24 du code
pénal permet de sanctionner les sites
qui diffusent des images pornographiques
susceptible d'être vu par un mineur
la loi existe la peine encourue est de
trois ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros d'amendé
mais en pratique cet article il n'est
pas appliqué dans l'univers numérique
la justice elle ne parvient pas à
atteindre les éditeurs de ces sites qui
sont souvent basées dans des paradis
fiscaux très loin et ne coopère pas avec
la france est ce une raison
est ce une raison la pornographie c'est
un univers particulier la pornographie
pour les mineurs c'est un univers encore
plus particulier les jeunes filles
s'identifient aussi avant c'était plutôt
les jeunes garçons maintenant les jeunes
filles aussi s'identifie on sait que
pendant la période de confinement il ya
eu des demandes de films pornographiques
qui vont exploser
et encore plus de films pornographiques
violents comment je vous expliquerai ça
simplement autrefois autres vous aviez
les films pornographiques films
pornographiques et vous aviez des films
pornographiques violents
c'était une catégorie pour des gens qui
étaient sado masochistes alors
maintenant on dit bdsm enfin je suis pas
familière excusez moi avec ça mais
c'était leur droit le plus strict d'être
attirés par des sites pornographiques
violents
on ne partage pas on essaie de
comprendre
dhr sauf que maintenant avant c'était
codifié violent maintenant le violent
est venu dans la pornographie j'ai envie
de dire excusez moi des deux bases
ça devient normal qu'une femme se fasse
strangulée serré écartelé et que 16 etc
mais oui c'est tragique et les petites
filles qui vont qui vont voir les jeunes
filles qui vont voir ça elles vont
vouloir faire pareil sert finalement
c'est normal que le jeune homme soit
violent avec moi maintenant c'est pas
normal du tout surtout quand on est en
construction comme comme cela est
expliqué tout à l'heure donc cet
amendement que je vous propose avec
vraiment j'ai envie de dire passion et
enthousiasme
il propose d'instituer une nouvelle
procédure destiné à obliger les éditeurs
de ces sites pornographiques à mettre en
place un contrôle de l'âge de leurs
clients d'abord le président du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel leur
adresserait une injonction de se mettre
en conformité que la loi la loi existe
puis il pourrait saisir le président du
tribunal judiciaire de paris afin qu'il
ordonne aux opérateurs de rendre
impossible l'accès à ces sites qui ne
pourrait donc plus être consultées
depuis la france on vous propose enfin
une action
même si on sait que c'est pas aussi
facile que ça mais au moins c'est le
début du commencement quelque chose ce
dispositif
il s'inspire de celui qui est mis en
place pour lutter contre les cercles de
jeux en ligne illégaux qui repose sur le
contrôle exercé par l'autorité de
régulation des jeux en ligne arjel ça
marche pour les jeux en ligne pourquoi
ça marcherait pas sur les sites pornos
l'adoption de cet amendement permettrait
de mettre en oeuvre l'engagement que le
président de la république avait pris le
20 novembre 2019 lors d'un discours
prononcé à l'unesco
le président de la république avait
donné six mois aux acteurs de l'internet
pour mettre en place un contrôle
parental par défaut sans quoi il serait
nécessaire de légiférer
on y est les six mois ils sont passés
ces faits les six mois on a là une
accroche dans la loi pour répondre à
l'exigence du président de la république
c'est quand même bien cette question
devait être traitée dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de réforme de
l'audiovisuel etc est remis aux calendes
grecques on sait très bien que ça va pas
avoir lieu dans les mois qui arrivent
donc c'est à venir il est incertain ça
va être chaud muette en 2021
donc ça ça incite à aborder à l'occasion
de cette proposition de loi
ces dispositions qui vont véritablement
protéger les mineurs vous allez me dire
les sites ils sont à l'étranger on va
enfermer à eelv ascension en ouvrir deux
dans la foulée peut-être mais c'est pas
une raison pour ne pas le faire c'est la
save et c'est là la fable du petit
colibri
il est un tout petit bec et à une goutte
d'eau pour éteindre un incendie dans la
jungle mais il fait sa part il porte sa
part nous avons la responsabilité de
faire quelque chose on ne peut pas
accepter de dire on ne peut rien faire
quand j'ai été élu maire en 2001 je suis
allé à la maison des ados on m'a dit
madame le maire ya un souci il ya des
ordinateurs regarder nos jeunes où ils
vont comment on va faire 2001 c'était ya
19 ans là j'ai expliqué aux jeunes à
l'époque qui avait 13 ans qu'il fallait
pas qu'ils aillent là dessus très
distrait et 19 32 ils ont trente deux
ans maintenant ces jeunes là et ils ont
le même problème avec leurs enfants
on n'a rien fait l'univers numérique de
nos enfants nous dépasse on ne peut pas
accepter d'être dépassés on a la
possibilité d'avoir une accroche ici je
crois vraiment qu'il faut qu'on la
saisissent tous ensemble pour protéger
nos enfants
merci madame la rapporteure
alors monsieur le ministre à vis du
gouvernement était le gouvernement va
essayer d'être aussi passionné pénétrer
que madame la rapporteure vous voulez
écouter les soeurs à vos propres
interprétations vous avez raison madame
rossignol je vais vous répondre même la
rapporteure vous avez raison
la seule disposition de l'article 11 ne
suffit pas à lutter contre ce fléau
qu'est l'accès des mineurs à la
pornographie mais c'est un ensemble de
mesures que nous mettons en place pour
que chacun des leviers en ciblant
parfois les hébergeurs parfois les
fournisseurs d'accès parfois les
éditeurs de contenus les plateformes les
réseaux sociaux pour qu'à chaque niveau
nous essayons de restreindre d'interdire
l'accès des mineurs la pornographie et
met à la porte vous avez raison de citer
le président de la république et le
discours qu'il a effectuée devant
l'unesco à l'occasion du 30e
anniversaire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant à
l'occasion de la présentation du plan de
lutte contre les violences car la
question de l'exposition des mineurs à
la pornographie est un sujet qui
préoccupe très fortement le président de
la république alors première outils vous
l'avez évoqué je l'évoqué tout à l'heure
ce protocole d'engagements qui a été
signé en présence de cédric au
secrétaire d'état au numérique avec
l'ensemble des acteurs c'est la première
fois que nous mettons autour de la table
l'ensemble des acteurs les associations
évidemment les fournisseurs d'accès les
grandes plateformes mais aussi les
constructeurs de téléphones
bref l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur
car nous pensons que c'est de la
responsabilité de chacun de pouvoir
restreindre cet accès des mineurs à la
pornographie
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé en
janvier dernier ils se sont engagés sous
six mois
la crise était passé par là pour être
très honnête les travaux continuent et
nous avons pris un peu de retard nous
sommes donnés rendez vous début de l'été
sous six mois pour être en mesure de
nous proposer un dispositif nous leur
avons laissé la liberté des moyens nous
avons fixé un objectif restreint très
fortement l'accès des mineurs à la
pornographie
donnez nous proposez nous les moyens d'y
arriver avec effectivement le contrôle
parental par défaut qui nous semblait
être mais ça reste ouvert
un moyen d'action efficace pour
restreindre cet accès si je peux me
permettre même la rapporteure le
l'adoption de cet amendement ne mettra
pas un terme ne mettra pas abba cet
engagement la part de l'ensemble des
acteurs cet engagement reste nécessaire
et nous continuons à suivre leurs
travaux qui sont menés sous l'égide du
csa et de l'arcep deuxième dispositif
brièvement l'article 20 de la loi bien
que vous avez adopté et qui a intégré la
question de l'exposition à la
pornographie des mineurs comme un des
champs de compétence de cette loi
troisième élément cet article 11 que
vous vous apprêtez à voter qui est donc
ré introduit dans le droit dur une
jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
vous l'avez évoqué qui dit que les
simples disclaimer ne suffisent pas
comme garantie à ce que les mineurs
puissent accéder à un site
et puis l'ajout de madame la rapporteur
qui confie au csa la possibilité
effectivement de saisir de saisir le
juge
étant entendu que le projet de loi
audiovisuel vous aurez l'occasion
peut-être de débattre peut-être une
forme un peu différente je ne fais pas
veux pas préjuger de l'avenir de ce qui
était prévu initialement mais prévoyez
vous le savez la fusion du csa et de
l'arcep
avec la création d'une nouvelle instance
l'art comme nous avions prévu et nous
prévoyons toujours que la question de la
lutte contre la pornographie
l'accès à la pornographie pour les
mineurs fasse partie des champs de
compétence voilà donc c'est un ensemble
de dispositifs auxquels l'amendement de
la rapporteure apporte sa pierre forte
utile qui je l'espère madame rossignol
permettra de restreindre très fortement
l'accès des mineurs à la pornographie
nous faisons pour laquelle la vie sera
favorable
si monsieur le ministre s'il n'y a pas
de demande d'explications de vote je
vais mettre aux voix l'amendement qui a
été présenté par madame le rapporteur
avec un avis favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement 92 rectifié est adapté
voilà pour cette séance que vous avez pu
suivre sur l'antenne de public sénat
pour plus d'informations n'hésitez pas à
consulter notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
on revient notamment sur cette actualité
dans l'article de simon barbarie voyez
porno de poing le sénat veut bloquer
l'accessibilité des sites aux mineurs
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]